no I don't think that because I think I
think there's a constant tension between
too much regulation and not enough and I
think in most cases too much regulation
is actually bad i think is it as
Americans we become even a bit too
comfortable with it more comfortable
than we should I think most Europeans at
least those that are enlightened would
suggest to you that they are at a huge
disadvantage because they are too
government intrusive and one of the
great I think saving graces of this
country is that government while it is
has implemented a number of very
important social programs it still is
very picky and choosy about which ones
they do and and therefore any argument I
think that says that more regulation is
a wonderful thing and they can prevent
all abuses I think it's a bit and I even
not very historically based in my son in
my view because we've had tremendous
periods where government regulation has
been very necessary and good from the
old trust busters under Roosevelt to
later administration's under the new
Roosevelt but but I think generally
speaking those were caused by events
that had to be regulated but to go out
and try to find new places to regulate
until you actually see a problem is a
tough equation it for you now to think
that bureaucrats are better at running
our economy then the participants that's
it that's a stretch for me
you